is it still possible for young people to
flourish in america big questions like
this usually make us think of top-down
answers kids can't get ahead because
capitalism is broken marriage is fail
because the media is setting a bad
example but psychologist yuri
braunfenbrenner's theory of human
development tells a different story he
found that children grow and make
decisions within a layered system of
relationships and that those
relationships with the closest proximity
to a child like families teachers and
strong faith communities have the
greatest influence
other institutions are important but
distant
government media and the larger society
matter less when the core is strong if
we want to truly empower children we
should partner with the people closest
to them
giving parents the power to choose great
schools teaching kids that the family
they form matters or helping young
people recognize the value of a personal
faith commitment
every single effort helps set them up
for future success
to learn more about yuri
bronfenbrenner's theory of human
development check out the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from aei